700.000 pro jahr fordern superkeime
schon jetzt und die zahl steigt so eine
statistik der
weltgesundheitsorganisation vero in die
millionen
multiresistente keime die immun gegen
verschiedene klassen von antibiotika
sind gehören wohl mit zu den größten
gefahren für die menschheit in unserer
zeit eine entdeckung im arktischen
spitzbergen macht jetzt deutlich dass
die gene dieser superkeime vor nichts
halt machen und keineswegs auf die
menschliche zivilisation angewiesen sind
und schon heute wissen wir wie viele
millionen in naher zukunft daran sterben
werden krieg zum science fiction
hier gibt es jeden tag spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
wir alle wissen vor allem in
krankenhäusern sind superkeime eine
große gefahr doch wie verbreitet sind
die multiresistenten keime dazu gibt es
bislang nicht wirklich aussagekräftige
untersuchungen auch wenn sie bislang
nicht nur den tieren und menschen
sondern beispielsweise auch in mehrere
sedimenten und böden aufgespürt werden
konnten
doch der spektakuläre fund eines
britischen forschungsteams macht jetzt
klar dass die gene derjenigen keime die
solche resistenzen übertragen nicht im
geringsten auf menschliche zivilisation
angewiesen sind denn die britischen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
fanden insgesamt 131.000 100
verschiedene resistenzgene im
praktischen boden nahe spitzbergen dabei
handelt es sich um gene die bakterien
die immunität gegen antibiotika
verleihen aufgespürt in einem eigentlich
unberührten ökosystemen doch selbst dort
gibt es offenbar kein entkommen klar ist
dass sich solche resistenzgene leicht
übertragen und verbreiten können und
zwar nicht nur durch den zell kontakt
zwischen verschiedenen bakterien sondern
sogar durch die luft dennoch waren
selbst die fachleute überrascht von
ihrem fund dazu david graham einer der
beteiligten forscher von der newcastle
university
die polargebiete gehören zu den letzten
unberührten ökosystemen der erde
galten daher als orte an denen man noch
resistenz werte wie vor der ära der
antibiotika findet konkret hatten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
40 bodenproben analysiert die vor sechs
jahren 2013 im nordwesten von
spitzbergen entnommen worden waren
durchschnittlich 66 genvarianten
enthielt jede bodenprobe dazu geben
diese gene verleihen schutz gegen
verschiedene antibiotika klassen
darunter die amico side die makro liede
und die beta laktamase zur behandlung
vieler infektionen eingesetzt werden
unter anderem auch dabei das extrem
gefährliche super resistenz gen mit dem
namen bmw m1 der nd mein stamm wurde
2010 in indien entdeckt und ist nicht
nur gegen alle gängigen antibiotika
klassen immun sondern auch gegen die
notfall antibiotika aus der gruppe der
kp nehme ihm das gbl an dem einst sorgt
für diese extrem resistenz gegen diese
erreger hilft tatsächlich nur noch das
giftige call ist ihn mit teils starken
nebenwirkungen
diese entdeckung des forschungsteams
zeigt wie sich solche resistenzen
ausbreiten und das zudem auch noch
weltweit und zwar auch in solch
entlegene winkel der erde wie eben
spitzbergen
auch die geschwindigkeit mit der sich
bella in dem einst ausgebreitet hat
erstaunt das forschungsteam sehr dazu
gramm weniger als drei jahre nach dem
bnd mainz erstmals in indischen städten
nachgewiesen wurde finden werden
tausende von kilometer entfernt in einer
region die bisher kaum von menschen
beeinflusst wurde das zeigt wie schnell
und weit reichend sich die
antibiotikaresistenzen inzwischen
ausgebreitet haben
nach ansicht des forschungsteams haben
höchstwahrscheinlich zugvögel die
resistenten keime nach spitzbergen
gebracht diese haben sie wohl in
südlicheren regionen beim überwintern
aufgenommen diese dann in die arktis
eingesteckt und über ihren kot
freigesetzt hat steht jedenfalls die
weltweite verbreitung solcher
multiresistenter keime ist eine ernst zu
nehmende und tödliche bedrohung für uns
und das problem ist menschengemacht dazu
gehören was die menschen durch den
übermäßigen einsatz
antibiotika auf globaler ebene getan
haben ist die beschleunigung der
evolution des rates und die schaffung
einer neuen welt resistente stämme die
es nie zuvor gegeben hat das fatale
daran dass bakterien eine resistenz
gegen antibiotika entwickeln das war
eigentlich abzusehen denn das volk ganz
den mechanismen der evolution diejenigen
organismen die sich ihrer umwelt am
besten anpassen überleben und können
sich vermehren durch zufällige
veränderungen in ihrem erbgut kam es
also dass vereinzelte bakterien weniger
empfindlich auf das angewandte
antibiotikum reagiert haben diese
konnten sich dann vermehren und haben so
ihre unempfindlichkeit an die nächste
bakterien generation weitergegeben ihnen
hat zudem in die karten gespielt dass in
den letzten jahren immer häufiger
antibiotika eingesetzt wurden sowohl bei
uns menschen selbst auch als bei den
tieren zu dem verschwenderischen einsatz
von antibiotika in der massentierhaltung
kommt oft auch noch eine fehlerhafte
anwendung auch bei uns menschen eine zu
kurze einnahme dauert gilt
beispielsweise als grund dafür dass sich
einige bakterien tatsächlich so
verändern konnten dass sie fast gegen
alle gängigen antibiotika resistent
geworden sind also noch mal zum
verständnis in der massentierhaltung
werden ständig dauerhaft antibiotika als
vorsorge gegeben das ist eine absolute
katastrophe
bei uns menschen ist es eine eben solche
katastrophe wenn wir die antibiotika
nicht bis zur letzten tablette nehmen
dann bleiben resistente keime übrig die
den nächsten menschen töten können und
so kommt es immer öfter vor dass gängige
antibiotika versagen und ärzteteams
nicht mehr wissen wie sie patienten
helfen können der absolute worst case
den studien zufolge sterben schon jetzt
jährlich weltweit 700.000 menschen an
infektionen durch medikamenten
resistente keime
bis 2050 könnte diese zahl auf achtung
zehn millionen opfer steigen wohlgemerkt
pro jahr
die sind die hochrechnungen einer
britischen expertengruppe im auftrag der
britischen regierung das hieße dann mehr
tote durch resistente erreger als durch
krebserkrankung mehr zum thema gibt es
hier wie wir selber superbakterie
züchten bei doktor watson unbedingt
ansehen und unbedingt abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran
[Musik]